a clark county school district coach is
out on bail tonight after he was
arrested for attempted sexual misconduct
he is 42 years old willie price books
junior is his name leaving parents
worried for the safety of their own kids
victoria saha joining us live with a
look into the arrest and some reaction
from concerned parents
yeah 42 year old willie price brooks jr
was the head coach for the girls
basketball team here at desert oasis
always says excuse me he was arrested
yesterday but today he posted bail
this is unreal to be honest with you
especially being a head coach of a girls
basketball team shock and anger from
desert oasis parents as the news of 42
year old willie price brooke junior's
arrest spreads all i can say is is
for parents
stay close to your kids
right know what's going on and
and hopefully
we'll come to a day where we can entrust
in our coaches again the clark county
school district police said the
investigation started earlier this month
after a 17 year old female student at
the school reported what authorities are
saying was attempted sexual misconduct
we know that our kids are looking at
these coaches as mentors and kids need
sports as an outlet pricebrook has been
employed by the school district since
2014 but according to the district is
now terminated he posted bill by this
morning that doesn't make me feel
very safe having my my teens out around
town i mean i do have a daughter that
attends desert oasis the principal of
desert oasis sent out this email to
parents wednesday informing them of
price brooke junior's arrest saying in
part the safety of our students is our
number one priority at desert oasis high
school
he is expected to be back in front of a
judge february 16. if you have any
information about this case please call
police reporting live from desert oasis
high school victoria saha live local now